we've talked a lot tonight about all the
people we want to lift up this black
history month but we missed one person
you
in this country in this pandemic you had
every right to give up but guess what
you didn't you're still here you're
strong you got your hair braided and
didn't shed a single tear until you got
home you woke up this morning and
started your day off as if this country
is going to do you right
it's not
these motherf will always be trying you
and you you'll always be bouncing right
back
i'd say that's cause enough for us to
celebrate say that it's tough you know
they're just jealous because
i get to wake up every morning
look at the same face i saw
20 years ago
hey
anytime's a music place
i can clap on the two
and the four
and it ain't even hard
you may try to fight it
oh you cannot hide it your hair is
versatile we can wear any style but
please don't touch our hair they're just
jealous of you
black i said black jump back
you're black excellent
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a community behind you
that cheers you on like they're all your
mama
but only one of them is your people have
broken boundaries
and they got the best recipes such a
recipe
legacy is strong
your whole lineage got it going on it's
in your dna you can't take that away we
crush it every day they just manage
y'all
i said black junk fat
[Music]
you're black excellent
[Music]
you don't have to set world records to
experience black excellence our
ancestors fought for your right to do
exactly whatever the you're doing right
now
woke up this morning that's black
excellent
you made dinner
that's black excellent
went to work for a full day and never
once popped off on a racist co-worker
man that ain't nothing but some love
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you